Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Savez-vous comment on reconnaît
un pilote de chasse dans une soirée ?
Non ? Pas d'inquiétude,
il viendra vous le dire.
Et je suis venu vous le dire.
Plus jeune, j'étais pilote de chasse
dans l'aéronavale.
Pour vous décrire quel pilote j'étais,
je vous dirais :
un égo démesuré,
un orgueil surdimensionné
et un profond sentiment d'invulnérabilité.
Sans oublier le blouson de cuir
et les lunettes de soleil.
Un pilote, c'est un gestionnaire
de situations complexes.
Il s'entraîne à gérer l'imprévu
et à faire face
à des événements stressants.
Ne croyez pas qu'il y ait
plus d'événements stressants
dans un cockpit d'avion
que dans la vie de tous les jours.
La différence : dans l'avion,
le pilote s'entraîne à faire face.
Tous les jours, surtout quand ça va bien.
La vie peut être remplie
d'événements stressants
auxquels chacun fait face différemment
parce qu'on a chacun
notre propre échelle du malheur.
Ceci dit, il existe
une sorte de consensus :
une étude qui propose
une échelle des stresseurs.
Cette échelle est très largement utilisée,
entre autres dans l'aéronautique.
Elle classe les événements de la vie
en fonction de leur impact
sur un individu.
De zéro à 100.
En haut de cette échelle, à 100,
on trouve l'événement
qui a le plus d'impact :
le décès du conjoint.
Le décès de l'enfant n'est pas évalué
dans cette étude,
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un stresseur
d'une intensité extrême.
Alors, sur notre échelle, à 100,
on a le décès du conjoint.
Vers 75, on a le divorce et la séparation.
Vers 55, on a sa propre maladie
et son licenciement.
Bien évidemment, il y a d'autres
événements et on peut les cumuler.
Et puis un jour,
un de ces événements fait basculer la vie.
Et ma vie, elle a basculé
un soir de décembre.
Ce jour-là, à cette époque-là,
ça faisait 5 ans que ma femme était en
chimiothérapie de manière ininterrompue.
Et depuis plusieurs jours,
elle avait des douleurs insoutenables.
J'appelle le médecin : « Ça ne va plus. »
Il me répond :
« Je savais que ça arriverait. »
Je ne comprends pas ce qu'il veut me dire,
ou je ne veux pas comprendre.
Le médecin prescrit des médicaments
que je donne à ma femme
et elle peut enfin s'endormir,
de se reposer sans souffrir.
Et ce soir-là, cela fait 48 heures
qu'elle s'est endormie.
Ce que je ne sais pas,
c'est qu'elle ne se réveillera pas.
On est allongés tous les deux,
dans notre lit,
comme tous les soirs.
Sa respiration devient bruyante.
Je lui parle, je l'enlace.
Je la serre contre moi.
Puis sa respiration
se transforme en inspiration.
Ses inspirations deviennent
de petites inspirations.
L'air finit par ne plus entrer.
Et puis quelques soubresauts
de ses lèvres, et plus rien.
Je ne sais pas
que je suis en train de vivre sa mort.
Tout s'est arrêté.
Dans mes bras, dans mes mains.
Quand j'ai compris,
le chagrin est monté en moi comme...
comme la foudre de l'orage.
Comme une vague qui m'a submergé.
Comment faire face
à des événements stressants,
à des situations dramatiques
et irréversibles ?
Il est impossible d'anticiper
la violence du choc.
Par contre,
on peut se préparer pour gérer la suite.
On peut préparer sa résilience
pour avancer sur le magnifique
chemin de la reconstruction.
Alors, pour vous parler de résilience,
permettez-moi de vous présenter
une population que je connais bien :
les pilotes.
Les pilotes sont résilients.
Ils s'entraînent à être résilients.
Vous prendrez l'avion différemment
si je vous dis qu'avant chaque décollage,
un pilote répète sa procédure
de panne au décollage.
Certains me regardent
avec des grands yeux.
Un pilote n'est ni superstitieux,
ni pessimiste.
Il ne pense pas qu'il va tomber en panne.
Mais il se prépare.
Il n'est pas question de prédire l'avenir,
personne ne le peut.
Même un pilote de chasse.
En aéronautique,
selon les statistiques, un seul accident
par million de décollages.
Pourtant, le pilote répète inlassablement,
tous les jours,
la procédure pour se préparer
à faire face à une panne.
Il met en place des piliers
sur lesquels il va pouvoir s'appuyer
pour faire face aux événements.
Il peut alors se concentrer
pleinement sur son vol
et vivre des émotions positives
dans des situations
potentiellement stressantes.
Il envisage alors sereinement
la possibilité d'une panne.
L'objectif n'est pas
de minimiser l'effet de surprise,
mais c'est de renforcer ses capacités
pour gérer la suite.
C'est le premier pas vers la résilience.
Bon.
Je vous parle de pilote et d'avions.
Mais c'est pareil
dans la vie de tous les jours.
Construire sa résilience,
c'est une démarche quotidienne.
Ça se prépare déjà quand tout va bien.
C'est tout ce qu'on met en place
maintenant
qui va nous permettre de gérer
et de construire
nos piliers de vie pour l'avenir.
Mes piliers à moi, c'est la famille,
l'amour,
mes amis,
mon métier, mes passions.
Ces piliers structurent ma vie
et ils ont toujours guidé
ma construction du bonheur.
Je n'avais jamais imaginé qu'un jour,
ils seraient la base de ma résilience.
Quand j'ai perdu ma femme, c'est
mon pilier de l'amour qui s'est effondré.
J'avais ma famille avec qui j'échangeais,
mes amis avec qui je partageais,
mon métier qui m'épanouit.
Quand un pilier s'effondre,
on peut essayer
d'en reconstruire un nouveau
ou on peut réaménager les autres.
Vivre différemment
autour des ruines
de celui qui s'est effondré.
Vivre avec le souvenir.
Il arrive qu'on cumule
les événements de la vie.
Et là, ce sont plusieurs piliers
qui peuvent s'effondrer en même temps.
La reconstruction peut être plus complexe.
Un pilier qui s'effondre,
c'est la structure de l'édifice
qui est remise en cause.
On a chacun un ou plusieurs piliers
plus solides que les autres.
Pour certains, c'est la famille,
pour d'autres, les amis,
la musique, le sport,
ou même l'argent, chacun son truc.
Les enfants sont un pilier majeur
dans la vie des parents.
Les enfants grandissent
et puis ils quittent la maison, le nid.
Bon, des fois, on est un peu impatient
qu'ils prennent leur envol.
Mais quand ils partent,
c'est un pilier qui disparaît.
Ça peut être un vrai bouleversement.
Pour certains, métier égale passion.
Un seul pilier.
Mais quand le métier s'arrête, ce n'est
pas un pilier qui s'effondre, mais deux.
Méfiance !
Structurer,
aménager ses piliers,
les entretenir :
c'est se préparer à faire face
aux événements de la vie.
C'est un peu une assurance.
Bien sûr, construire ses piliers de vie
est d'abord une démarche individuelle.
Mais c'est aussi une démarche
avec les autres.
Une étude réalisée
dans les cockpits d'avion
montre que certains équipages arrivent
à gérer l'imprévu de manière optimale.
Alors que d'autres n'y arrivent pas,
ou moins bien.
Ce qui fait la différence,
c'est bien sûr la préparation,
mais c'est surtout la communication
entre les membres d'équipage.
Cette connexion qu'ils auront établie
va leur permettre d'avancer ensemble,
de s'impliquer ensemble.
Pour construire ses propres piliers
et aider l'autre à construire les siens.
Des publications récentes en psychologie
montrent que lorsqu'on aide l'autre,
on crée un bonheur
qui profite à trois personnes.
À celle qui est aidée,
à celle qui aide l'autre
et en plus, à celle qui regarde
ceux qui s'aident.
Souvenez-vous pendant le confinement,
on a vu toutes ces initiatives
de solidarité.
Ça ne vous a pas fait chaud au cœur ?
Cette connexion aux autres,
elle nous permet de construire
notre propre résilience
et celle de ceux qui nous entourent.
Grâce à une écoute,
un geste, un regard,
grâce à nos mains, à notre cœur,
grâce à un je t'aime.
Quelle richesse, non ?
Chaque nouvelle journée,
c'est un nouveau départ.
Un nouveau décollage.
Et pour se préparer
à faire face aux événements,
pour
vivre des émotions positives,
il n'est pas forcément utile de vouloir
tout changer ou tout anticiper.
Pour piloter sa résilience,
soyons simplement attentif à la structure
de notre quotidien.
À ce que l'on vit maintenant.
À nos piliers de vie.
Des piliers que l'on peut construire
pour soi-même,
avec les autres
et pour les autres.
Et vous, c'est quoi, vos piliers de vie ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)